la mobilisation continue au sein
d'Alcatel Lucent à véisie suite à
l'annonce de la suppression de plus de
1400 postes en France la direction
prévoit également la fermeture de ce
site historique des Yvelines l'activité
devrait être transférée à noset dans
lesesson avant septembre 2013 ce matin
syndicats et salariés ont organisé le
blocage d'un bâtiment une troisième
action coup DEP afin de faire plier la
direction c'était l'occasion pour nous
de montrer que on est capable aussi de
perturber un peu le travail et que que
le plan de licenciement et la fermeture
de véisi ça se passera pas en douceur à
10h on avait une assemblée générale de
avec les salariés on a eu 600 personnes
quand même qui sont venus à cette
assemblée
générale pour un effectif ici qui est de
normalement autour de 2100 mais a priori
quand même moins de salariés présents
avec le télétravail et cetera 600
personnes c'est c'est pas mal on est on
est assez content de la mobilisation
pour l'instant l'objectif de l'assemblée
générale c'était de discuter enfin de de
présenter au aux collègues les actions
qui sont prévues
euh on a ce qu'on a de prévu c'est euh
une manifestation euh jusqu'à la mairie
de vellisie pour bah pour parler aussi
de la fermeture du site parce que les
licenciements
euh c'est grave la fermeture du site
c'est un des moyens qu'utilise la
direction pour pousser les gens euh à se
à à se à démissionn pour euh pour
réaliser son plan de licenciement donc
nous on combat à la fois le les
licenciements et la fermeture du site
euh on a aussi euh en prévision une
manifestation au siège social rue de
sufren à Paris euh probablement une une
manifestation enfin à l'occasion du du
CCE fin novembre où on commencera à
discuter effectivement des euh des
vraies mesures du qui vont être mises en
œuvre pour le le plan de licenciement et
euh bon là on continue d'essayer de de
mobiliser et de monter en puissance sur
cette mobilisation euh la question de la
grève a été évoquée aujourd'hui je pense
que on finira par en arriver là si ça si
la direction ne recule pas